et nous retrouvons maintenant j'ai un
respect refondateurs du webmagazine le
monde décrypté
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france on apprend à
l'instant que des premières discussions
ont eu lieu entre le président américain
joe biden et mahmoud abbas joe biden qui
s'est entretenu plus tôt dans la journée
avec benyamin netanyahou le premier
ministre israélien
sur quoi peuvent déboucher ces échanges
à la fois avec les palestiniens et les
israéliens
bien sûr d apaisement parce que la
situation est quand même difficile parce
qu'elle a se compose de trois volets un
volet de société il y à 1 heure sociétal
entre la composante israélienne et la
composante arabe dans dans l'ensemble de
la région
donc il y à un militaire on voit des
phrases très très nombreuses et puis
aussi un volet politique avec la
situation donc de netanyahu qui est un
premier ministre sortant qui peut être
premier ministre appelant ou rappelé
donc ce qui peut intervenir entre donc
le washington et l'ensemble des parties
et bien c'est un appel au calme un appel
à la raison à washington a repris depuis
quelques semaines le financement l'aide
financière au prêt donc des autorités
palestiniennes
donc il y a une capacité de dialogue de
la part des états unis 1 qu'il n'y avait
pas il ya quelques mois lors de la
précédente présidence américaine
donc là il y a une une ouverture
effectivement possible au dialogue et l
écoute recontextualise ans si vous le
voulez bien j'ai un respect les tensions
ont éclaté il ya une dizaine de jours à
jérusalem
estelle push maintenant la cisjordanie
mais aussi à les villes mixtes heures en
israël comment en est on arrivé là à cet
embrasement qu'est ce qui a mis le feu
aux poudres d'abord il ya effectivement
un fond de problèmes que nous
connaissons tous donc qui est
l'accroissement des colonies
l'accroissement du mouvement doc de
grignotage du terrain
en cisjordanie à deuxièmement il y à un
moment on est arrivé là
à la fin du ramadan donc un moment de
fête de la libération
le ramadan ce cas une contrainte donc là
on a envie de s'exprimer
et puis troisièmement il y a eu ses
dispositions pour pousser certain nombre
de familles arabes en dehors donc de
jérusalem s dans la dans le quartier de
cheikh jarrah
donc il y a une donc ces trois volets
le fond du problème un moment à la fin
du ramadan et puis une étincelle qui a
provoqué l'explosion
vous évoquez aussi à l'instant des
considérations d'ordre de politique
intérieure est ce que l'extrait
l'extrême droite israélienne se sont
portés par les dernières législatives
quand les palestiniens de leur côté se
sont vus retirer
récemment les premières élections
législatives depuis quinze ans est ce
que tout ça joue aussi dans le
déclenchement des récents événements au
proche orient
je ne sais pas si on peut dire que
l'extrême droite a effectivement le vent
en poupe n'est ce pas le likoud a qui
est là quand même la composante de droit
de principal est réduit à 30 sièges de
la knesset le likoud pour une majorité
de 61 61 sièges n'est pas donc à même
d'avoir la majorité dans la majorité
30 + 31 et donc la situation est très
compliquée il y à un émiettement
politique en israël qui correspond aussi
à un émiettement idéologique qui
favorise les extrêmes
face à ces tensions qu'elle rejoue à la
fois le hamas et surtout l'iran mali
vendée n'est pas notre bien sûr l'iran à
son camp il faut le lire et écouter ce
que dit le guide suprême de la
révolution c'est effectivement la
suppression de l'état d'israël c'est
l'objectif ultime donc lui rend est de
substantiellement le jihad islamique
ed avec l'armement il faut te regarde de
très près les deux types de requêtes
qui ont été utilisés et d'ailleurs on
doit s'interroger sur la la qualité et
la portée de ces équipements militaires
une roquette normalement remporte à
quelques kilomètres là nous avons des
requêtes qui font 70 80 km de portée
certaines dépassent les 100 kilomètres
donc il y a vraiment un franchissement
dans les performances dans la qualité du
matériel militaire mis en oeuvre et qui
est d'origine iranienne
alors on a parlé de ces échanges récents
entre joe biden et israël comme avec le
présent l'autorité palestienne plus
largement de quelle manière ce que la
communauté internationale peut
participer à votre foi au caire au
proche-orient et quel rôle joue-t-elle
en ce moment mais il y à des appels au
calme qui viennent de toutes les
principales capitales à de moscou à
washington en passant par parier et
bruxelles donc il y à une demande de
réunion effectivement au niveau de l'onu
aussi pour inciter l'ensemble des
belligérants à à revenir à des attitudes
qui soit beaucoup moins belliqueuse à il
y a encore certainement une ou deux
journées un peu difficile où les
requêtes vont continuer à être tirée
mais le stock de roquettes n'est pas
inépuisable
donc inévitablement nous allons vers un
apaisement
maintenant ils relèvent des politiques
d'accélérer cet apaisement
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation j'espère je rappelle que vous
êtes fondateurs du web magazine le monde
décrypté